their roles were vastly different yet
each managed to steal our hearts they
are this year's outstanding nominees for
actress in a supporting role the
nominees are Kate Blanchet in the
Aviator Laura Linney in Kinsey
virginia madsen in sideways
Sophie Okonedo in Hotel Rwanda
Natalie Porton enclosing
and the Oscar goes to Cate Blanchet in
the area
this is the first Academy Award and
second nomination for Kate Blanchet she
was previously nominated for her leading
role in Elizabeth
thank you very much um thank you to the
Academy who know Katherine Hepburn so
well and is so intimately acquainted
with her work
this is an indescribable surprise and
honor thank you I know you think it's
cheesy sweetheart but I have to thank
you my husband and Hilda queerly and
Robin garden and my uber agents and the
wonderful Lisa Costello everyone
involved in the Aviator when you play
someone as terrifyingly well-known as
Katharine Hepburn it's a collaborative
effort you need as much help as you can
get and thank you of course to miss
Hepburn herb the longevity of her career
I think is inspiring to everyone but
most importantly and on behalf of
everyone I know in the Aviator thank you
to Martin Scorsese I hope my son will
marry your daughter thank you